a tour I was on tour for a few months
with the last movie we made which was
called Jay and Silent Bob reboot so we
did see seven cities in three countries
and our tour ended February 26 in New
Orleans the day after Mardi Gras
Wow though I know honestly it was we
look back over the tour every hot spot
we were in like a month or two months
ago or something like that and all that
time I was on the road I never got so
much as a cold and I was doing a lot of
like interactivity like we were seeing a
thousand fifteen hundred people a night
but then after the show you do like meet
and greets to take pictures of people
right somebody comes back give them a
big hug and stuff yeah so I'm really
surprised that I don't have the plague
or something like that after all that
exposure or maybe it's kind of built up
my immune system I don't know so when
you know I got home I was looking at
like being home for two days and then it
was back out on the road like South by
Southwest was coming up and I had a
movie debut in there that a documentary
that I was there not one that I made and
then the the Tribeca Film Fest oh I was
scheduled then suddenly things started
getting canceled which at first was a
bummer but then I was like you mean I
get to sit around the house for a little
while yeah it's the lockdown in the
quarantine like you know I know it's for
árbol reasons but personally I'm not
going crazy I'm you know I lose a lot of
time I wake up in the morning I'm like
I'm alright
then I said I read in the news and
suddenly like it's 4:00 o'clock and I've
all I've done is so I gotta learn to be
productive again at the same time you
know I get to I get little things in
like I've been working on this Netflix
show masters in the universe this anime
reboot that comes out in 2021 so you
know we're we're into the animatic stage
so I've been able to watch those and
like throw in some additional dialogue
and script so every day there's like a
little bit of work that gets done but
mostly it's this weird kind of
netherworld where
days don't really matter anymore and
it's either like bright or dark and
that's the only difference
yeah they all kind of blend together
after a while programming man so I you
know I went through I was on tour when
the Mandalorian drop so I didn't get to
see it right I've ripped through the
Mandalorian which was excellent it
reminded me of like a TV show from the
70s which is about the highest
compliment I could pay something I was a
child in the seventies and stuff yeah so
that's where I watched a lot of my TV's
seventies in the 80s and that show felt
like something straight out of the 70s
in the best possible way and very very
Star Wars I've been watching little
fires everywhere total soap opera it's
pretty amazing
I watched onward which the biggest
mistake I made was wakin bacon and
watching an odd word because if you've
ever had a dad or brother movie just
like get you right here so I was born
watching that what else about what of
course Tiger King like everybody else
yeah everyone's a good king it seems
like it's required
do you hate Harold Hoskins now honestly
none of them seem like real people like
right you know you watch the miniseries
and it's almost like a live-action
cartoon word not for the fact that a lot
of big cats got hurt and killed like the
whole thing is kind of ridiculous to
watch and not not ridiculous bad it's
insanely well-made but all the people
don't act like normal people I think
that's what people find so fascinating
about so cartoonish yeah at least so
that that was a really fascinating watch
what Elsa moving it ingesting yeah I
went back and started watching old
things I watched his old movie called
the freshman with Matthew Broderick and
Marlon Brando it's from like the early
90s and actually held up was pretty good
what about you what are you watching
yeah I was gonna say we I finally caught
up on like Chernobyl because I came out
Asian and I
I know right I yeah here's some other
people who can't breathe and I was
watching it I was like aha man I feel
like I can't breathe right now or so I
mean it was incredibly well made and I
absolutely [ __ ] loved it but it came
out ages ago and we came back from like
an LA trip and we were jet lag and I
watched the first episode and I was like
I mean it's good but I'm not really
hooked on it and then we started
watching it again like we couldn't put
it down it was sensational on our hands
it's like well maybe I can yeah so we've
been me and my girlfriend she's a she's
huge into like Japanese stuff and she
speaks the language and everything so
she loves horror movies so we've been
catching up in a lot of Japanese horror
movies which so many that I had never
even heard of I never watched the
original grudge movies I always shitty
American the one the American yeah
that's cool why you're sitting around
yeah I know I should like do more with
it
I should write some work justification
like so when did you start oh dude
everyone's been gaming their whole life
about seven years I've been doing the
YouTube thing seven years and in that
time you've amassed the audience they've
amassed that's insane man how are you
every day you wake up you must be like
oh my god I get to be me for a living
this way yes there's there's a couple of
moments where you kind of you get sucked
into like they like show business he
aspects of it but you can't have to pull
yourself back and remember that it's
it's a really cool [ __ ] job that I
get to do and so many people would do so
much to be able to do it so and me seven
years ago wouldn't have thought that it
would be where it is now and now we get
to raise like we're all we're pushing it
on half a million dollars raised and
like I mean you know you guys built an
amazing community and and it's nice that
you guys can turn to that community in
time and need and be like hey let's help
out some other people yeah really really
sweet I was with it we got to do it
through the internet which is even
cooler
very very cool give me the moment like
because there's been many if you've been
doing for seven years and you
watch the business exponentially change
when was the moment that you realized I
will never have to work the way I
thought I would have to work another day
in my life like I get to be this one
when was that exact moment um probably
in the first two years I think the first
year and a half was like nothing was
happening I was making about ten dollars
a month on it and then it went from
making $10 a month to making thousands
and then it went up and up and up and I
I could find like move out of my home
and move away from my parents and fund
my college and have my own place and all
these different things and I it was
probably during that when I hit about
500,000 subscribers that it was like
okay this is sustainable this is
something that I probably be able to do
for a long time and isn't gonna change
anytime soon
and if this upward trend keeps going
then I'll be in a very good position so
it was pretty early it worked out really
well so beautiful you know I know a lot
of kids today grew up in that world
where like you can watch people game but
like you know you talk about seven years
ago like 15 years ago this wasn't even
like a made-up job in a sci-fi film
right then it's so wonderful how like
creators can create even based around
stuff like I'm gonna sit here and play a
game which is creative like I remember
when we were kids like Star Wars toys
we're all the rage the action figures
and there are some like parents watch
groups that were like this is not play
like play is going out in the yard and
kicking a ball or basketball or hockey
or whatever playing some football this
is this is not play and yeah slowly like
that maybe the perception didn't change
for everybody but I became a storyteller
and there's a direct line between me
having those action figures and you can
only you know do the movie so many times
right like you know if you're gonna
replicate the movie you can only do that
a few times before you're like well what
if they did this and then you start
creating an adventure and that's writing
so like at that point man I could
draw you a line from me playing with
action figures to me doing what I do for
a living and you know back then in the
beginning people were like well that's
good stuff and now it's like literally
talk about action figures make a living
off of that I have loved over the course
of the last 25 years
just watching cuz I came from indie film
and that was kind of like a self-made
DIY thing but watching other self-made
DIY communities pop up and it's just
it's fascinating and it like I I'm never
like like on some level I should be
jealous like oh my god that I'd like get
played games for a living why didn't I
think of it yeah I'm just so happy that
it's the thing for anybody like when I
was a kid the closest thing to get paid
to play a game was like if you were a
Milton Bradley tester or something yeah
but it's amazing I'm like this is what I
do for a living like for somebody from
the outside nothing but like a steam and
Wonder Man is cool what you've been able
to accomplish
that's I appreciate that thank you but
it it is one of those things either some
people hate it and some of that
perception is still there if people be
like that's not a real job like you're
playing games for a living you should
not take it too seriously blah blah blah
anything that creates an audience like
that's a job that's like saying like by
that same token a stand-up comic is not
a job like of course it is you put asses
in seats guess what that's not your job
that's your [ __ ] career at that point
yeah and you can put asses in seats like
by sitting there and playing games that
says like something that a lot of people
would just miss is like that's you're
playing a game it's like it's but you've
turned it into a creative endeavor yeah
at the same time like that's if
everybody out there in the world who
sits there and struggles sometimes and
goes like why can't I do this and this
sometimes you got to look at people that
have done things even things that aren't
in your field or purview and take
inspiration from it and for people that
like would knock like what you do for a
living who are just like that's not a
real job like that ain't the way to go
what I would do is like even if it
irritated me that somebody was playing
games for a living I would use that as
fuel aspirational fuel for myself
because I'm like look I have no respect
for what they do but if this person has
living doing that anything is possible
and I write excuse not to pursue my
dream as well so not only do you get to
do it for you and any family I'm sure
your parents were ecstatic when you like
moved out and stuff like by playing
games inspires other people to chase
their dreams do you get that like my
line of work where people like hey man
like [ __ ] yoga hosers made me want to
do some like yo ghost [ __ ] I've done you
can never tell what it is something one
aspect of your story your life story
touches somebody else and fires them up
it worked for me that way because I saw
Richard Linklater's film slacker in 1991
on my birthday and I was like I think I
if this counts as a movie I think I want
to try to make a movie and stuff yeah
and so it lit me and boom so I'm sure
you're lighting the fires of a bunch of
people out there and have been doing so
for years and not just in the gaming
world but people who are like oh my god
if this guy could do that maybe I can
open a restaurant it's crazy how inspir
yeah that's kind of what I hope people
gleam out of these events that we do
because the majority of what I've done
today is just say it with a camera and a
link and be like here go donate but so
many people who do the charity thing
expect it to be so much harder than it
actually is you can make it harder you
can make it expect achill you can put on
a show and do stuff and every now and
then we'll do it for Christmas where we
do it all dressed up and everything put
right it really does not take that much
if you have an audience and anybody can
literally go away and do this what I'm
doing right now for this exact event and
if you just want to do it then just pick
up a link and go that's really all it
takes you have a phone you have more in
your hand now than I did when I started
off doing this so you just make a vlog
you can make a video you can go live on
YouTube or Instagram or Twitter or
anything these days and just make a
change in someone's life and sometimes
I'll be honest with you like you know
despair is infectious
depression is infectious if you're
sitting there reading a you know a
depressing news cycle it's gonna worm
its way into ya
every part of your look on life and how
you interact with people this sounds
like a dad type thing to say but like
something I've noticed over 20 he now 26
years I've been doing this [ __ ]
professionally if you throw yourself
into creating something it's incredibly
therapeutic number one just on the basic
level of it takes it distracts you away
from all the negative news and focuses
you on something refocus use you
completely on something that's not
related to like all the depressing news
that's going on yeah number two there's
two paths in this world man there's
destruction and there's creation and the
destruction path was filled like impact
because it's easy to break things down
it's easy to tear things down it's easy
to mock others and stuff like that and
not put a little piece of yourself on
the line Krejci landings are wide open
because it takes a little bit of oneself
to be like I'm gonna put this out there
you know for fear of mockery for fear
failure which is the bigger thing don't
ever be afraid of failure the only
failure in life is not trying the thing
that you dream about trying and unless
you're doing the thing you dream about
trans killing people don't do that if
your dream is just like like you know I
watched Jackie plays games like why I
would like to do that do it give it a
shot man doesn't mean you're gonna be as
successful as input like yeah you will
have this success
that's not measured in viewers or money
or something like that it'll be a
personal success of victory over doing
nothing over the sameness of doing
nothing like creation is the cure man
and I'm not saying it's always going to
lead to success people getting rich it
becoming a job like you and I are sanely
lucky and as much as we chased our
passions and it turned into something
but even if it didn't turn into
something for me I still would have kept
doing it because the thing is worth
doing in and of itself man like right
when I saw people making indie films I
was like that they're human beings just
like me I mean they're not like robots
or aliens or some gods like these are
normal people and they're just picking
up a camera
doing an extra normal thing you know
sometimes it requires like a reasonable
amount of unreason ability you know
reasonability dictates that you can't
make a living playing video games and
stuff but you had an unreasonable a
reasonable amount of unreason ability an
unreasonable amount of unreason ability
is when you're like I'm gonna fly
without jetpack but a reasonable amount
of unreason ability is gone like I know
there's a status quo and I know how
things go and I know it's expected of me
well I'm just gonna shift to the left or
to the right and see what happens
like right that's a reasonable amount of
unreason ability it's not people online
take you know there's lots of unreason
ability and nobody ever wants to move
from their position nobody ever wants to
be wrong
this isn't about right or wrong this is
about looking at the world and the way
most people perceive the world and how
its set and how this is what you're
meant to do and this is what other
people do and figuring out your way into
it a backdoor into it if you will which
sounds sexier than I meant it but like
that it's it's definitely there for the
taking and if you take the time to be
creative in any way sitting down like
you know writing a blog is the obvious
thing and when I'm talking about picking
up popsicle sticks and time together
like just you know making a thing you
wind up having like taking your head out
of the negative game more importantly at
the end of it you have a thing to show
for your time learning something that
not everyone can ever say in life like a
thing that is uniquely yours that
wouldn't exist without you making that
step forward so as we all sit inside and
and what not aside from helping people
today and people that absolutely could
use the help help yourself when you've
done the time help yourself towards
something that like for years you've
been like I've always wondered if I
could do that sort of thing oh my god if
you've never had the time to try now is
yeah you have nothing but time yeah I
keep I keep trying to encourage people
well it's it's funny to see as well
because you kind of see what's important
to people now during a time like this
when everyone is forced to stay at home
they figure out oh this
is more important to me than I thought
it was and this is really not that
important anymore this that whatever you
the trivialities of going out and how
you appear or how you think you appear
to other people all of that stuff is
kind of washing away for people and for
me it's like picking up shows that I
didn't watch and stuff to try and get an
inspiration here and there but I see so
many people who are picking up new
hobbies people are reading more people
are like playing games they've never
played all that kind of stuff is just so
cool to see and like you said what
better time to do it now when you're
forced to stay inside and you can't
actually do anything else it's
absolutely true and this is one of the
only the first time in my lifetime I
remember anything remotely like this
like where the whole world just had to
stop you know and now that we've gone
through it or we're going through it I
know it's you know hell on the economy
and whatnot but yeah there's something
to be said for like you know a month
break this is a world that never ever
stops and like in you know that's it's
horrible that we're all inside and
horrible that people are dying of course
and horrible that well you know we're
facing the pandemic but at the same time
like weird like little miracles have
popped up like the porpoises coming back
into the Venice canals yeah toxic cloud
you know over the industry heavy
industry in China like dissipating for a
minute like the earth is seems like it's
taken a moment to heal so we deal with
phone calls in this house but like you
got to find silver linings sometimes to
the direct right now that that is a
silver lining a bit like maybe the earth
has taken a moment to heal because lord
knows we keep it working 24/7 yeah for
sure to to change tracks a little bit
Michael from tilta fire who was setting
all this up and helps out and everything
he messaged me asking how did you come
up with Silent Bob Marie Curie's on it
because I wanted to put Jason Mewes in
the movies the guy that plays
so I true American original
he's got twitch channel and stuff he's
something of a gamer but you know he's a
long way from me but that's his passion
that's his hobby sometimes it's it's on
twitch just makes Legos and stuff like
that right so Jason one of the most
original human beings ever you've met a
true one off and I hitched my wagon to
star years ago I would always like say
man you're funny like I wish somebody
who put you in a movie I would love to
see if other people think you're as
funny as we do or if you're just Jersey
funny instead right and then years later
when I saw slacker and realized oh I
wanted to make movie I realized I was
gonna be the one to put him in flew like
I was like I'm totally putting you in
this movie now Jason's
stream-of-consciousness is kind of
brilliant like basically he's he's just
always entertaining to be around always
has been he needs no help so I wanted
him to like the Jay character to
essentially be Jay just constantly talk
in and yappin and stuff like that but I
didn't steal him for him to speak to
because you know he was brilliant
even of himself so I needed somebody to
stand next to him that he would always
be talking to so that he wasn't just
standing in front of convenience store
talking to himself and salaries and
stuff and the other guy didn't have to
say [ __ ] because I feel like Jays gonna
just say it all he's motormouth so I
wrote the part for that reason to
balance the Jay character and I was
intending to give it to my friend
Michael bellicose who I grew up with
he's in clerkes he's the guy who's like
Dante goes 37 my girlfriend's
secretaries are dicks he goes in a row
that's the guy who I thought was gonna
play Silent Bob I wrote the part for him
I was gonna play Randall the guy who
works in the video store
Jefferson play because you know that's
why he has all the best jokes but as we
got close to production I was like I'm
not an actor my [ __ ] thinking and I'm
barely a writer and I know I'm not a
director but like I can't act I can't
memorize all this dialogue so I gave the
part to Jeff Anderson but I was like if
this is the one and only movie I ever
make and I was putting it on my own
credit cards and stuff like that I was
like if this is the only time I'm ever
gonna make a movie if this don't work
out whether we're
or not yeah I at least want to be in the
movie that way like years from now as
I'm still paying this [ __ ] off with
three jobs every once in a while if I
ever get the notion like you should try
that again I'll pop this tape in and see
what I looked like when I made the worst
decision of my life so I said I'm gonna
be silent plus I know Jay real well and
EJ had never acted on camera so I could
be that much closer to him and like
telling him how to act and what to do
and say like that so I wound up backing
into the part like it was me gone like
well I took the part away from Mike I
was like Mike you were gonna play some
Bob but I'm gonna have you play this
other guy's a cop care and I took Silent
Bob III was wearing a long trench coat
in those days because I was a big fan of
the comedian Sam Kinison he wore trench
coat and so I decided to take that into
the character as well and the backwards
baseball cap I wasn't even a baseball
cap kind of guy but I figured it made
him and gave him an edge so right on the
backwards baseball cap and all of that
[ __ ] like that was not the aim I was not
like this is what I want to be in life
I'm gonna be sad about I backed into
that [ __ ] and it defined the rest of my
life like this you know got done touring
Jay and Silent Bob reboot a secret Jay
and Silent Bob strike back that we made
18 years after the other one so it's you
never know the thing that's going to you
know become your passion George Carlin
who was a my favorite comic of all time
and just a brilliant creator in his own
right he didn't want to be a stand-up
comic he wanted to be Danny Kaye in
movies the Danny Kaye the song and dance
man from from like Hans Christian
Anderson and stuff like that yeah
that's who he wanted to be comedy he
just did as a side gig and yet that
defined who he was and who he is and we
still think of him as like one of the
greatest comedians that ever lived so
sometimes you aim for something and then
something else becomes the goal when you
started playing on YouTube I thought
that's my version of exactly how it
started playing like was the end game
this or was it just like I'm doing this
because I think before
now people watch me play again I mean
always gonna be the latter because I
wasted so much time playing games and I
was younger anyway
and then when I was when I was like in
my it was on-the-job training exactly as
planned but I I went to college for like
music stuff I I played drums at the time
and I wanted to learn more about drums
and music and how it was made but my my
course was kind of all over the place
and it wasn't focused on music solely so
I kind of lost interest in it and left
and then I I kind of fell into watching
youtube people because I played a lot of
games and I wanted to see how you got
better at games how how do you learn
this game better how do you shoot those
guys faster and I I happened upon a
couple of youtubers who were doing it
and I didn't know that it was a job I
was watching them do it and they were
just doing it for their own spare time
their own amusement and they were giving
over tips and then I I started doing it
a little bit myself because I thought
that's fun I was miserable I was
depressed I had didn't really have any
friends and I had nowhere to go and I
lived in such a shitty place that I II I
just wanted to like yelled into the void
and hope that some people shared the
same sort of opinions and kind of came
back to me with some sort of like
positive vibes and I found the people
who kind of clicked with me and then it
was ages after that the youtuber was
like yeah so this is my full-time job
and I [ __ ] blew my mind
I never aimed for that I just found out
at that point that you could do it as a
job and then I just kept making and
making and making and the better I got
at it the more I could do it and I went
back to college again and luckily I kind
of took off since then but no it was
never ever my intention that it would
turn into what it is now I I didn't even
know this is a possibility back then I
didn't know you could do this type of
thing to this level back then and you
know what I hear and kind of in the
center of your origin story is not that
dissimilar from mine you you had to find
you tried first he had to find your
people like thank God for the Internet
man pre-internet like we couldn't find
each other once the internet happened
then you could find like-minded
individuals but not only did you find
like-minded individuals
you found like-minded individuals that
like set you on a path like where
suddenly you were like this is the
possible
so anyone like to me because I saw
slacker and that made me want to be
filmmaker
Richard Linklater is like a Mount
Rushmore named for me who were your
Mount Rushmore names when you first
started like YouTube gaming Oh God
well the guy that I watched first who
was doing like battlefield 3 videos he
was his name was level cap gaming and he
was just he was good at the game he gave
over like insightful information and
then he he started opening up and
showing videos of his life and his vlogs
and finally found out his name and
things like that and that that kind of
like assuring away everything and kind
of opening himself up to his audience
was one really inspired me and then guys
like PewDiePie were doing it they were
massive at the time and they were just
like they were the Soaring thing that
was everybody was watching it everyone
was obsessed with it because it was the
most fastest rising channel of all time
and those kinds of things always just
inspired me to to to just get out there
and kind of try stuff for myself it was
cool to see them and hear their stories
and hear where they came from and knew
that oh they're they're not that
different to me because the thing that
always happens and I I've done a live
show tour as well where I can get to get
up and talk about my life and explain
where I came from and who I am and it's
it's kind of stand-up comedy in a way
like so not only did you now like the
dream job but you also figured out the
adjuncts as well where you're like well
if I can do this then I bet you I can
stand on a stage and just talk about my
life yeah yeah and it's it's not in a
comedic way and we kind of just take
stories from youth but the the whole
message of the show at the end of it was
that was to show that I didn't come from
anywhere special it wasn't some sort of
miracle there was no a secret wine that
I drank that gave me superpowers or
anything and I'm here on a stage talking
to everybody because you just you find
something you like you persevere you
work hard a little bit of look and then
you end up kind of where you are and
it's that thing where you hope that some
people go out of that room and the show
ends with the line be the hero of your
own story so the hope is to like give
people that story to be like yeah you
can do it it's not the
difficult you just have to work hard at
it sometimes and then it will work out
doesn't work out for everybody but if
you're not trying then you'll never know
so damn true and sometimes like like
early on when I started my career of
course it was like all about me I wasn't
thinking about anybody else's like I
want people to see my movie and I want
to sell mono then the longer you can if
you'd be lucky enough to get in the
longer you stay in in the job it's less
about what you can get out of it or what
you want then like this sounds weird and
it's gonna sound like I'll mean it to
sound this lofty but there becomes this
weird responsibility like to the
audience yeah because you got there
through a specific means and you got
there by being in the audience and it's
it'd be weird to get to the other side
and then pull the ladder up we're
[ __ ] you know burn down the path so
that nobody could follow you so once you
get in there suddenly after a while you
want to like like that's what drives me
it's not like we got paid this ooh like
critics said this what drives me is like
the audience going you know I watch what
you do and like it makes me want to do
something right and that's your payback
the same way that like you know watching
slacker made me want to do something and
then you realize if you're one of the
lucky people who's you know got picked
or whatever and ascended like you want
to be that person for somebody else you
want somebody to be like look that guy
know better than me but he did this
thing that girl she's no better than me
but she did this thing yeah and like try
it because then that says a lot about
your legacy it's weird like you spend a
long time hoping or dreaming to get like
a dream job or something and then when
you get it at a certain point it becomes
about what is this all gonna mean well
yeah how long will this last and what am
I doing with that time and stuff and so
the idea of like telling people you
could do this like I think about ten
years
my career is when I started getting very
vocal about that you know and this for
the last 15 years it's been telling
people to like go make [ __ ] go create
make something make your own thing you
never know where it's gonna lead man at
the very least the very least you have
something that not everyone has and it's
your very own at the very most it could
become it Jag's life my life for
heaven's sakes yeah yes that's good
advice better than that I mean that's
the thing like some people probably look
at us and they're like you guys aren't
aiming high enough ya know it's stuff
definitely God very crazy very quickly
for me and then it was that thing where
you kind of just pulled by I could be
like I could keep pushing this thing a
million miles an hour but I think I'd
burn myself out and I wouldn't enjoy it
as much and if it just becomes it's
great that it became a career but if
it's if that's all it is anymore then
why am I even doing this because like
you you get to a certain point we're
saying okay I feel like I can slow down
a small bit I can actually just enjoy
myself and do cool [ __ ] with it rather
than just trying to constantly gain and
grow and amass more people I'd rather
appreciate what I have and who have come
then try and push it further constantly
just because I can so smart yeah I I I
get that like incredibly successful
people like you know or a void that
cannot be filled so they'll keep going
even after yeah like they've won but I'm
like remember that moment in aliens
where like Ripley finally takes over and
all the Marines for getting killed by
the aliens and then she [ __ ] starts
blowing people away and she gets sliced
drags Hicks into the car and you know
they're all like we're gettin outta here
and she's just driving like [ __ ] met
at a certain point it's just like ease
up Ripley you're just grinding metal
ease up I always think of that when it's
like like you did it like you did what
you wanted to do man like it's not about
world domination it was this one thing
you wanted to do and then beyond that
you did all these other things like he's
up
you're just grinded metal at this point
man like you've taken it pretty damn far
ambition is a wonderful
thing but it's also a haunting which
sometimes you know it leaves you in this
place where you read about somebody
else's success and suddenly you're
measured against your own and yeah
things have no relation to one another
and so it's taken me years man but like
I I know how to deal with those feelings
now whenever I feel like if I have some
feeling like you know I'll read
something online and you get like
jealous or mad or something like that
and then it's able to figure out oh I
know what that is that's just me worried
about my own relevancy
however right I I did a thing like relax
like you know you're there like you
don't have to you're grinding metal and
stuff that ambitious voice the same one
that gets us where we want to be never
[ __ ] stops and that that's the only
downside because you'll get to a place
where you feel like I think I'm content
I [ __ ] rock this I can't believe I
got here and then that [ __ ] nagging
voice which was good enough to get you
there in the first place
just keeps going like what if it's
satisfied with this you have to figure
out how to balance the voice of ambition
particularly once you get to a place
that you considered being achievement
and never let the world tell you whether
you succeeded or not you know whether
you succeeded or not yeah absolutely
well Kevin I think we're gonna have to
wrap up the call here but thank you so
much for coming on and chatting it's
been the expert this is exactly my type
of conversation I love this [ __ ] and
everyone at home has just been like
talking about it and saying how
inspirational it is so I think you've
you've definitely lifted some spirits so
thank you for creating like take your
mind off and stuff like yeah thanks for
having me thanks for doing this oh no
problem thank you thanks for taking the
time no prank well thank it's good
chatting everybody in charge say bye
yeah real world someday we'll cross
paths yeah we make it happen yes yeah
bye
you